you don't like it no I do not
on our way and then here for Baba to do
my hearing a beige it's hard to do her
hair cuz she has so much hair do you
think I do good braids Nora no I'd love
to make it a fun I'm gonna do a really
simple hairstyle so I'm hoping you do
that thank you for dinner vez are you
nervous about this dad to your daughter
sir for the first time and then I
finally growing up no I can't stop that
if I mess this up you're gonna be mad
yes I do know how to braid but I haven't
done it since I was seven yeah like
eight well I didn't do something right
again I don't know what I did wrong just
be making a ponytail huh no I'm gonna
braid it this is not how you get french
braiding extra movement is just gonna
really throw me off well you guys follow
you it's gonna throw me into confusion
does it look okay yeah I think we've
made your braids you do best it up huh
yes you do which one do you think is
better yeah why why did he do a good job
my dad is a really simplistic it's not
like everything in her world putting
somebody tear my dad doing my hair
scared me but he's definitely getting
better at this while he's trying to get
better
it's payback time so what are you gonna
do to my hair how are you do it see I
have no hair so you did a great job it's
awesome